وكلمه للمدير العام لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
بشان التطورات الاوضاع في تركيا وسوريا
التي
تمر بها العائلات
الذين خسروا اما اما او ابا او بنتا او
ابنا
بين الانقاض
او اولئك الذين لا يعلمون ان كان
اللاعب احبتهم على قيد الحياه ام لا
الاعداد لا تخبرنا حقيقه الوضع
العصيب الذي
تواجهه العائلات التي خسرت كل شيء اجبروا
على النوم خارج بيوتهم في فصل الشتاء
الان هناك سباق ضد الزمن
كل دقيقه
وكل ساعه تمر
ان فرص العثور على
الناجين احيانا تتضاءل
وما زالت نكهه
ارتداديه وظروف فصل شتاء عصيبه وطرق مدمره
وسائل الاتصال والكهرباء
هي تعتبر عائقا الان بسبب
عدم قدره الناس للوصول
الى ان
جينج
هناك توقع
بزياده الحاجه في المستشفيات لمعالجه
المصابين والتركيز الاولي الان هو
متعلق بانقاذ ارواح الناس ونحن قلقون بشان
المناطق التي ليست لدينا معلومات عنها
لفهم الحاجه لتركيز اهتمامنا
فاننا نقوم بالعمل
بشكل مستمر مع فرق الاداره التي تعمل على
الصعيد المحلي والاقليمي والدولي ونحن
ايضا نقوم بحشد
كل ما يلزم لحالات الطوارئ وفرق الطوارئ
لكي يكون هناك تقديم رعايه صحيه
للمصابين ولمن هم في وضع هش ايضا
هناك صعوبه
في وصول المعدات
من مواقعنا في دبي ونحن نعمل
عن كثب
لدعم البلدين
في الساعات العصيبه القادمه وفي الاشهر
والسنين القادمه فيما يقوم البلدان
بالتعافي واعاده البناء
لاخواننا واخوتنا في تركيا وفي الجمهوريه
العربيه السوريه نحن نقف الى جانبكم
في هذه اللحظات التي يسود فيها الحزن
العظيم
هذه لحظه يجب ان نوحد جهودنا فيها
كانسانيه وبشريه واحده لانقاذ ارواح الناس
لتخفيف العناء
لدى اولئك الناس الذين
عانوا اصلا لدرجه شديده جدا شكرا يا مايك
ونعود